consumption lounges in Vegas will need
locals as customers in order to have
continued business the locals will
really be the ones who support the
company and we're waiting to see if
they're really interested in this the
first few months will probably see
locals excited to experience the lounges
because it's the first time ever
happening in Nevada but from that point
we're waiting to see and hoping to
create experiences that make it worth it
for them to keep coming back over time
the piece that is a play for tourists
because it's Vegas of course we have to
cater to the tourists is that these
locations many of them will be
absolutely spectacular and they'll be
things that no one has seen in any state
that they're coming from in any country
they're coming from because it's Vegas
so we'll do these lounges in in a way
that hasn't been seen before in this
industry
I'm Julianna Whitney co-founder of
leafsheets.com and founder of can
strategy Leaf sheets is an online
platform that's helping cannabis
entrepreneurs get into the Cannabis
industry by providing basically a Legal
Zoom model of what it takes to get into
the Cannabis industry and to operate
your business
applicants for cannabis consumption
lounges in Nevada are worried about how
competitive the process is and how
involved the process is there's a lot of
steps to it right now we're facing step
one which starts accepting applications
October 14th to October 27th there's
things like business licenses needed
ownership information applying for agent
cards and then in addition to that A
diversity plan which is required by the
state in order to uphold their goals for
diversity and inclusion in the industry
and that piece is really tripping people
up because it's not something that
they've created before or dealt with
before so we're getting a lot of
questions about that then when all those
pieces are put together the applications
are reviewed and then people who get the
minimum score their applications are put
into a lottery system and from that
point it's all up to chance and that's
the most concerning and most
nerve-wracking piece for a lot of the
applicants that we're seeing the state
will accept applications from October
14th to 27th then they'll need some time
to review those applications to conduct
the lottery once the lottery selections
are made there's a set amount of time
about 120 days for people to get all of
their standard operating procedures
together do a suitability review and
then upon approval of that section of
the application then we've got 12 months
for these lounges to get open we'll see
some open sooner than that because the
dispensary owners who will have lounges
a lot of them already have spaces built
out so we can expect to see lounges open
in Nevada by quarter one quarter two of
2023.
a successful cannabis consumption Lounge
in Las Vegas will look number one
beautiful it'll be attractive to both
locals and to tourists and it will have
a business model that could survive even
if cannabis were not part of the
business model because we can't just
lean on that as the number one Revenue
generator so you're going to see some
spectacular Lounge Concepts that will
provide one-of-a-kind experiences and
then the bonus and unique benefit will
be that cannabis is also available at
these locations